last time we went out here
i don't know if you still remember that and
i have a little oh i'll
find out now what i'm worth myself
so without joko without national team
without materia without Toten Hosen without
formula 1 without Luis Hamilton without whatever
because  up until that point I
always hid behind I
was always just once a year
for us, traditionally, there is the big
Paul Ripke update what is Paul doing
in California what does he live off of
all this now in this conversation
again  let's go hello very nice it
's nice to be here again
everything has changed again in November
I wanted to be there for a short time but somehow
I wasn't in the mood
to talk right now and um that's why we
went to the sauna is still my
favorite  day last year i have to
say i spent with you uh
already said that he then i build
us a little excitement also a
swiss blast denied what a
better men then put together that
was that was really that was
a nice day Philipp thank you very much  very much
so thank you for being
there with me I'll start with
the difficult topic because it was
originally thought that we'd
do a recording there and we'd
meet so much and then you
said well in the  It's better to
wait a bit and see what happens
and you don't know for sure because
you've
experienced a little shitstorm as part of a
marketing campaign for Weight Watchers yes, I think I can say
I was at the lanzarhof
before that and I have a yes how  because such
an intestinal cure makes a fasting intestinal cure
done and had a double
shitstorm so if you understand
the shittiest place in the truest sense
of the word or something like that happen but yeah like
that it's sometimes yeah the um yeah
I've learned a lot I have to say and
um
but I always write it was about
pointing people to an offer from
Weight Watchers and then
ads were placed on Tinder and I
think that technically a
lot went wrong that a lot
was forgotten but in the end it
’s one thing  I think I will
at some point not be 42 years old anymore and
what I know is that I'm giving up the habit of
talking negatively about someone and
then also about partners and that's
why I wo
n't really say anything negative about Weight
Watchers here
because that  I don't think that was
intentional, but something
went wrong and what came out was
theirs again,
so it's not what they
want to transport and especially
not what I want to transport,
I think that you were accused
or the campaign was accused
not fair or should one say
being aggressive towards women or
pretending to be something else than in the
end, so to speak, exactly me, for
example we have one, the
advertisement looked like a tinder profile
and that's not okay and that's
how I said it is  I learned a lot from it,
so from now on I'll actually have
everything released in writing where a picture
and my name appear in it from all
cooperation partners, which they
made a bit more relaxed before, so
you work in the industry too,
that's sometimes sometimes necessary
I think there's a reason to
be strict and I'm
a lot stricter now because I
've realized that something just
came out that wasn't too compatible with my
values ​​and when I
took the consequences, we
ended the collaboration immediately
and  I have to
say that I was at the point where I
got a little bit out of balance with things like
cooperations, advertising, own projects,
support things and so on and
that was all at a time when I
stopped with Viva  to work last
year and didn't find anything new,
but that was always important to me,
so I worked
intensively with Viva Connect for many years and
always found it very, very good and there
was something there was also a hole something
what  I didn't fill it right away
and so on, and I also
supported a few people in the last year,
so it's always been
important to me to give a little help to people who
might have deserved a little support
with my eyes
I also
did that less than I was already a
bit imbalanced and
I have changed that now I am about our
conversation today I have a wall like that
and I write like this and I think
about the visual I notice then
we can do that right away  then do it once
I can at least see if it's halfway in
balance then your life
is exactly those are your own projects cooperation
right partnerships and support those
are the four axes that exist, so to speak
and ey in the end you have to
say again so with that with that with  there
is one thing that
I have really used professionally in the last 15
years,
including Formula 1. For 4 years
I have worked and lived really intensively according to
one rule and
it is never ask for permission back
for  forget
and if you benefit as much as
I have over the years, you
might have to live with the fact that you
might also be able to do it on the other side,
so I have the feeling that you
don’t want to have all these results,
that you somehow nope
the other way around, that I was there in the course of something
like that, maybe they
did that to me too, you know, I
sometimes imagine that that
understood
because I don’t think anything that
I was careful, but I don’t think
that anyone either  there was
an agency involved in all of this, there were
different people involved, I do
n't think that people
realized what strangled it in the end, what it came across like
and um accordingly, but nevertheless
it must be clear to people that it must
also be clear to me that is  also one of the
things I have to be clear about how it
comes across in the end where my face and
my name is on it and so on and in the
end
the biggest learning or
maybe you can
answer me better what I don't so
that was interesting that
Topic that is Fridays is on tiktok
Saturday is on tiktok Sundays it is
on Twitter they all quote tiktok where to be
fair really so there
were things that weren't right
so that was just factually partly
wrong which didn't
make it any better but  nevertheless it's
not a journalist who
wrote it down neatly and on Mondays
all the media in Germany
reported on it at once 74
publication of Spiegel
Zodiac signs
can that be a cell phone or you've
probably done it then it's
done differently than that all the time and
I am  not so relevant so sorry that
can so I'm not so relevant that
74 media reports about it but I
well that surprised me a lot and
maybe I
learned that from the fact that
I have to be a little more careful
and so on  have
to be more controlling and in the end I
clearly took the rudder a bit more
towards my own projects and
that wouldn't have happened to me yourself you know
I have to be so transparent
we both know each other on the
outside so that's how it is for me too  didn't
happen before 12 years or 14 years
or however long I've been doing it
and accordingly um I have to
take a look at my own nose and change myself a bit
I'm doing it and I've
already done it now it's somehow
April 5 months later and um, I hope
that there is something else that I
have learned, in any
case, then we'll let the axes
go a bit, but that means with
the support,
so why do you have
something again that I have here  would not want to discuss
would actually okay but in the
end there was something and you have
something new in the support area so I
now have the Stuttgart helps that is
super Serkan you did
not recognize by the way bad that I
say that wrong
mega cool guy that I have  I've
never met anyone who appreciates
the goodness of people so blatantly, so he goes to
Ukraine, he was immediately in the
earthquake area right after I did
a podcast episode with him,
we did a fundraiser,
so in addition to the money, it had
a similar structure
On the one hand, we really need
donations that
come in as donations in kind, but we also need money
for an organization and we've
done half of that and um, so that they
can survive for your
business and
I have a very good feeling that very much  a lot of it matters
because uh, I'm
very, very satisfied and also proud to have
met him.
I met him through Karl Kauer, he came
around in the Stuttgart area
somehow and I've
heard about him a few times and he has
then I simply invited him to the
podcast, so that's also one of the
things that I have for me, I
already have the podcast and newsletter in addition to Instagram,
I have two, three, four,
five platforms
where I at least think that
maybe I can use that too
for more meaningful things than always just
swipe off there is now this and that and
um campaign so there I was also
happy to collect money right there so
there I doubled every donation
that someone from the listeners can
understand made over the first week
that's not a very small
number 70,000 € you then added it again from
your private money
so that's a lot of money um yeah
totally yes so and and that and it was
always important to me I don't have, well
I don't know, any aqua donations that are
publicly visible  I don't want to
know so I'm already someone who
I also tip a lot because
I've really
been extremely lucky in
my life and absolutely
happen to have financial success
as well so it has nothing to do with my skills
like sometimes very hard work
well, we're about to come out of the marathon
and we're just sitting there, but it's
really just absurd when you compare that with
a serious job
out there, and that's why
you're doing something American here in Germany,
but you
have no idea yesterday what  It cost €21
and I got €30 fits like that
and they look at you very strangely
sometimes you have to say
with Joko where you or I know it
because two people around me
keep telling me that they stole it from
you  this trick erm or
this trick and this idea of
being in a restaurant and then just
unexpectedly paying for other people's food
and going out and
not looking at all but
should I until today so I
did it three times last week and so on
I find it  I mean, you
leave this restaurant with a big grin on your face and you
're happy about it because they do
n't know at all, so I
always make them promise me that they
won't come out while it's been paid for
and why or what, there's no
reason, that's relatively random me
find people but what are you looking for the
selection that looks likeable or
because the gut feeling sometimes I
've
invited someone who where the mood wasn't that
good table I think they were like that
I would say based on gut feeling they
were adult sons so his
parents  or maybe they're
separate I don't know but it was
irritable and then I thought oh
come on
maybe that's something and I'm
not really sure if it
was that good because I think maybe
that was it too  then encroaching
so I don't really know
if it is, but I do believe that it
is positive and I also believe I
really still believe in karma,
so I believe in it and I have
it again in such a way
very strange well I opened a couple of
clubhouses in Berlin and then
you can
get your clothes that you brought to life years ago together with about you that meanwhile have your own
pariskey now you are also here
in Paris completely so there is
something to get  a store or a
clubhouse in your corner in
Newport so um and now you have but
he says okay
we just have exactly the same thing too so
I still believe in stupid
ideas so little charming if
something fits well I already have  got told
about 60 times in the last four years,
just do a pop-up
store in Germany, do
whatever, the point why it
totally convinced me was that it
's red too and that's the similar layout, so
it's on the right  there's a store on the left is
an office like in Newport Beach on
Later Street
right in the middle of Mauerpark and I think that's
also the reason why it's so cool it
's two weeks old now and it's
extremely successful and when I
go there and  open the door people stand there
and buy paris and that's awesome
even if i put posters there's a queue because
if i don't post
people still come prime and now nope much
hotter i sell i've
already sold things several times where people
even  don't know who I am
so they just like the clothes
and the location and that's
the biggest thing for me if someone is so to
speak detached from me if that happens
at some point then I've
managed everything then it's all
friends who run it as an advertising agency
they are in other studios
said here you can
have it first and so on and not that
’s just not that great a business plan
no one sets up so it’s
actually voluntary and this
voluntary and first of all at eye level
just say come on do it so I have
no idea if  you would say now
if you have something here in terms of
real estate then you
probably want me to put it down now
but then she will say yes, just
take it for three months I'm happy
about it if I do something there too
can be cool with our too you
helped me I helped you
whatever so I think that’s on an
equal footing and that’s how it was there too
they give me that now
I can do a bit I
put a mirror foil on it  i
basically have it is also red like the android okay
and we built it almost identical to the
newport thing in berlin and also
right in store as i said and um
we sometimes roll the dice because i come from
heidelberg and there was the sugar shop
and one of the  biggest institution was
Jürgen and he rolled the dice at the end
of the purchase process and you got a lollipop
if you got a six
and sometimes dice come up again
and so on and then I still do it to
this day at Paris for every buyer who is
physically with me in  Newport or in
Berlin now I buy with the cube
and I'm a very, very bad
businessman so my goal is that
the one actually so six packs
66% discount that's quite a lot of
time I've got a lot on it so
super cool idea uh so to speak also as
yes, how should you put it, as a
customerationship management or
as an experience event in a shop
to somehow adjust the price,
it makes you want to go and
of course everyone leaves happy
think
that’s really cool and I’ll tell you the
statistical survey of the  The last three
days in Berlin is of course not so
I'm not a statistician and everything is fine
but we also do [ __ ] then someone
rolls a 5 and
he can roll the second die again and then
it's a one or two again and
again a one and two  and then
he threw four times and then I say
okay the fifth throw is a last
throw, we have to do that now
we have to earn some karma and
then there are somehow 40 people
and then I say all 40 have to
do ten squats now  and then
all 40 people who are there have to
tine together the process is plenty of
weed but also a bit funny but
also together and do you know how often the
guy then rolled a five
it must have happened ten times exactly
Karma can perhaps be worked out in
that  all together these five
I already realize that that's nonsense but
it's it was really
extraordinary what happened this time
and that's a
really epic moment because all 40
cheer like again that this guy
55% sure loading like  do
things like this happen in the store when you're not
there if you're still alive there
's no staff there either so we'll see
what's going on so after that
we'll see what's going on question for
you I was so now we have if there
is a  There's a reason now the film club is coming
out and we've got that in advance, for
example or something like that
then it makes sense I don't know yet
if we're going to do it Monday to Thursday,
so we definitely don't open
without any but also the office
is bigger  and there's a podcast
box in the middle that's an OMR of
about 1-200 of them, that's how I see
it too and the main term for it is
uh that's a vocational youth center that
's really important to me and
that's always been my offices  were
always vocational youth center so it
was just kind of like that you can
come by there you can drink coffee
then you can somehow
work something there you can do something so
it's just like that but
always on a completely
different level that you  this
professional youthfulness
is only a bit less at 42 but
then at some point it grows out or
you say it's actually the same
as ten years ago it's getting
worse for me so like that I
really only do more and more what I feel like
and that's what I see  me as a
young professional so that you
really make young people are easy to a
profession and he has no idea we
got Paul pocket money last week
you know so they are Maultaschen but they
used to be called Maultaschen now of course they are called
together is so I think there is actually
a lot in there  the thing
for the OMR listeners who
are already interested in marketing and how does it
work and I listen to your
podcast which is really great and there
are a lot of insights how to get
there and sometimes you learn how
ticking like influenza  you
actually get it how how do
brands work so how are there
different new direct to consumer
shopping fire brands and so on
is really interesting to see and
Paul Taschen is really really what
where I am first and I have
a lot of collaborations  all cool and
everything is great but
Sättele is for the first time such that a
commercial company is a
spaetzle and maultaschen manufacturer the
hot saddles that you don't know them they
are probably the second largest spaetzle and
maultaschen and
liver dumpling manufacturers in the world
and that's why they make
a company so involved  I don't know about a few 100 people
but they're already big
and the story starts with Karo
Kauer we have a podcast we're talking
about Paul Taschen I say I'd
like to do that then listen to the citizen of the citizen
is the largest manufacturer is sort of
the audios below  the uhm yes citizen
hears it in the podcast that is
actually quite often that happens
very often when you talk about something
and says I would like to
make Maultaschen which are then called Paul Taschen and
bring in a little twister uhm
then listen to the citizen so it is  Yes,
nice on the podcast some headphones in it
then passes it on to the person who hears
it, then they know, okay, that's
somehow halfway relevant and then
someone gets in
touch, they got in touch and said we
heard that too, that's great and Paul
We think bags are funny and
what do we want to call, I
said yes, we'll call right now
and I went into this phone call
and it was so cool we're making Paul
bags now and she's but when are we going to make
them and and how can we I'd be
up for it  to bring something Californian in somehow
and then maybe
a bit of protein and whatever
please excuse me we do
n't make any extra product yet we
can if it's high you can
visit the Spätzle world
near Stuttgart
production line that that now and
You can then perhaps get exactly
and then I said
unfortunately we won't get together but you
're welcome to come by and I'm actually
all good I want to award the product I'm
serious and that's what
I mean by professional youth I
mean that then  Seriously, I want to
make Paul bags like that and
I told you that again and
then said it wasn't a huge success
with Bürger and then Sättele got
in touch and they were on an equal footing from the start
and it was just the
managing director with one  his I
think it's the assistant so it
's really crass where the whole thing in the
so with me hasn't
been like that I don't think I've
made that many wishes but even now
here at firm and fluffy they
said that they  would like to
comment on this Olympic Song Contest
would suddenly do that
now yes it's been
done this effectively in the podcast
very very well
probably many more examples
can come up yes but it's amazing yes okay
unbelievable because that's just the way it is it's a
spoken word  what is there and what
can be recommended and there is no
other place where it is so good do
n't know is gone so you can
go let's think about
where you would still like to work I
think Lufthansa is my big
wish and for me Lufthansa that
I have a cooperation with Lufthansa
which I live in America
still a lot I that my only
unfulfilled wish is Lufthansa
so you have to say a lot to Lufthansa
and maybe
Lufthansa will listen at some point and I
am too but what else do you want
Chair or something like that in first class
I want to work with them I
want to fly to travel destinations that might need
a bit of help
telling a story in the podcast,
video and photo, whatever else I do,
but what is it called, so you have to do it
your things where party Paul
bags that's not a good pun
Lufthansa a little air they have no
but so winners just don't fly uh
there's a story of the winner
planes we are there in terms of content
I fly a lot with Lufthansa and I have to
authentic cooperation because I
really like the product  So what I
really like is what I do right away
I would think I would say
down-to-earth would actually be in the
normal class as well as at Stuttgart
Barre in Berlin at the bar in the Grill
Royale where a seat like that
is somehow sewn in and then a regular seat and
then white  you even if you're not there
hey you know what I flew with the
plane where Paul Ripke regular place in the
air force I would have been funny I
don't think I think you're going
again such a funny
communicative that he's your department
that  also correct i think but that's
cooperation we
might get to where things work
and where they don't work erm i
think that the output is not enough
that you simply say to the customer oh i
was sitting here on this thing i think i'm
actually supposed to be around now  to be serious for a moment,
that you could invent stories,
so not just invent them, but create them,
so that you actually need to be creative, so
Lufthansa stories that
's an emotional product, a trip
to Bogota or a trip to Chile or
a trip to wherever I have, for
example 98  Countries traveled in my
life and I'm still missing two Formula 1 there's
a tick on the back of 100 who
a really great story with Lufthansa
or something like that you know and then
again before that the ten best and I
take photos because I might take
someone with them  on site then there is
a travel topic because in the end
Lufthansa is exactly there for that they make it
possible for you to tear and I
think travel is very very important I think three
are actually very very
enriching and if I had 5000 € too
much I would  always
put a trip straight away and not in a car
or something but the very first thing
you should do is travel if
nothing has benefited me so much and my
whole environment and all the people who
are successful and inspiring have
one thing in common the trips all very
many of them  have different
cultures and countries and people and they
left their comfort zone earlier that's exactly what it is and
you notice it like me right now so I
hope but
back to
contact the goods are on an equal footing they
understood the gag they
said okay we have  here
already built a packaging that was
n't quite like me it was still
a bit too cool I kind of shot
back and said look,
they have to be just like the saddles
packaging so the Maultaschen of
which I just have the M with me  replaced by a P
and it says original
Swabian on it and then I
made original Californian polenta bags and then I also have a
bit of a cheesy picture of me with
a heart from California so that
a bit of a Californian atmosphere
comes in on top of it and it's nice
so the packaging and the
way it is so that if I
were to give that now then you would
say okay that's funny in
any case there are
videos where you're sitting in a uniform
with your cap on a cash register
and we have  also done so what we did we
developed a product
so and they actually
brought protein for the first time worldwide into what was then still a Maultaschen so the
really high protein as a product that
has a bit of cranberry in it so that
something fruity from California
gets in there and that  means the product is
also really different is unfortunately not
vegan because vegans don't like it quite as much
as it is vegetarian, there is also a
bit of cream cheese in it and
we used the product at my
marathon when they did this
carploading two days before  OK, because the
party used to be, now it's the Paul
bags party, back here in Berlin with
the Kraft runners, it was a sensational
evening, then we made an offline lounge
where they were physically available
in Eislingen near Karo Kauer, and
people banged on our doors, and then
we  filmed that and
put it out and then we have an
online lounge one job because
dough were fresh items and
you can actually only
really mail them in April and that
's not a director you can mail
business so that's that  Product was
really
available once we
sold 10,000 pieces within an hour and um they're gone but in the
end it's hard so I mean
honestly
sold out for an hour online
is a good sentence that I
can say that at the OMR podcast  that you
that that's easy and that's because and
I'd like to say that again
that um they didn't flow a single euro
no, they didn't
give me any money I didn't give them any money on the
side they are simply on an
equal footing with me  communicated I
paid for the location, e.g. in Eislingen, they
paid for the product and so on,
but they bought an output of it.
I posted about it 17 times. I
posted about it ten times. I
probably have no idea the
€150,200,000 worth of marketing output they
get  but if you only
thought because they were attentive because they said what is that that's
a joke from Paul
we'll try as hard
as he does that apparently
communication isn't a permanent
product rollover where it's supposed to run for years now  that's
why it's then
look when Edeka
jumps on it says well I mean it
was sold out so quickly and so well
people write to me every day now
so get them back and so
on well that's really like that, come
people in Berlin to the store  and say
you have Paul Taschen but in the end that's
how marketing works these days or I mean it
's actually the new world
of marketing
you can't always be lucky as a company
that you would
like to do something like you now that you're
there now  but
looking for opportunities is right now, recognizing stories
and then working with strong
personalities so deeply integrated
or at eye level and
not and that's something that
a lot of people say then you can always
please post it can start the logo or
a video  Can you please
pay attention as a brand where is
my added value in there and they
never did that, they always
said first of all we want Paul
to find it funny and in the end we
got 40 times the value
because of it  because she worked with me on an equal footing
find it very funny you know the greatest thing in the
world you think you also need it in the end
to exist because I have to be
stories of young people that's the
answer so I find nothing nicer
than doing exactly that and that's
actually the case  well that's
also so there were also certain amounts that were
sold and that was then
too you know we actually had
a first world problem that we said
okay we now have a turnover
what do we do so here's money now
and that  e.g. my shop and they
in turn also have mega move from them
said you didn’t earn anything from it we
don’t have anything so let’s donate
and have donated everything back to
step by the way and that in
turn will be so I believe in something like that
it’s really right from a chamber point of view
but you also created that
finances itself so people who hear the the the
question is in the end how does
this life of crazy is to me
it used to be clear you have as a
photographer you have somehow
but service providers I
took photos exactly and then you have  somehow
full of Formula 1 or get money from Mercedes
and things like that are
understandable but now
the big partnerships
that you have as a person support you there are
somehow I know from IWC exactly
I got to know you through you
very very nice very nice [ __ ]
we are  both big fans so but also
I think they get so have huge
supply problems I think because the
watches aren’t available because so many
people see it like we
have to also find a company that does really well and
I think Maurice understands it
who you think I also
work great guy and who also
comes from hip hop no so he just checks
why creditworthiness works he checks the
internet he knows who is cool
right now which is really surprising
that someone at a luxury watch
manufacturer knows when they  Nature is
right now or something like that, you know, that's
um extraordinary and familiar to the server
from CEO level and
you always notice that, that's similar
to Formula 1 back then, toto it's
also intuitive to people, there's
nobody who's such a blatant  So
in my perception, like dead wolves ever, he had an understanding of human nature and, based
on this gut feeling, he
trusted people who almost always
have one thing in common, they were always good
at their job, whether it
was Instagram or whether it was aerodynamics or whatever, um
that was always
good, but that means in the end IWC is already
a partnership where I
have five partners
five is the magic number to
build really great cars,
but above all with them we do a
podcast with IWC  IWC
we do different activations, so
I'm going to Miami now and I'm
also creating media, so on the one hand,
they always come into my world
and with me, wherever I
do something, whether it's a podcast or a newsletter on
Instagram or any event whatever
in mine  world take place and
then there is always the fact that I
take place in their world with all
partners so that I either
produce content for them that I become the
link between fans and a
visitor George Russell comes to
the factory and I then walk through it with him
or we shoot a bit of
funny tiktoks there or we
always do something in Miami or wherever erm that
sort of I just mean content for
the manufacturers so I mean yes
I still make content so I
produce media like that and these two
things happen  then always and at
Porsche there is a great deal of community
building, so what we actually
discussed again a year and a half ago at the very end is
that brands are actually all
going to the community now and not
so much to ariens and that they checked
that  the community is worth much much more
and Porsche
actually checked that quite early on in the end and
made such a brainstar and in
the city center in Stuttgart and the
examples I keep using them again and again,
for example, unfortunately, unfortunately, unfortunately, there is
a big conflict in terms of appointments, that’s why I am
I'm not at the watch this year, I'll do the store there for a week
and it didn't work any differently than during
the week and take over and then do it
there during the day if it's rent for
speed, you can sit down with me for 15 minutes
and do something  discuss
whatever you think you
need to discuss with me then we'll do
a job experimenting a Paris Porsche or
Porsche
uh has a special value
because I can't tell you from my car yet
uh and then or
scratches it yes but we'll take it  out of here
we cut it out now we're
back in the ear and just
cut it out
exactly
fitness tracker so to speak lifestyle
tracker rather really a cool app that
i really blatantly babbled on
so I hated as hard
as actually
maybe yes well  so i got to
know now
i also work at eye level nee
american sit so is a seat in
bosten is a totally numbers driven
crazy crazy guy wants is who
also really interesting for you i think
wants but what is your name in
his  American company in than so
when many many messages I
made PDFs from Cola apps that have
the cameras out in Germany now
I still mainly have
a German community that I burden
but meanwhile it's getting bigger
than we're talking about almost 100 now
Millions of people my Instagram which
I still don't understand but
I think it's because of podcast because he
's a different guest every week because I
so the one point I don't check
why I'm on Instagram steadily
growing for two years was actually
I thought  there is actually no
real reason for it anymore, so the
Instagram people must have somehow
heard from me, I think, and
deliberately said if we do
n't follow now, for example, but um,
it's already all getting a
lot of German, but I do  the
last five years from so four
years ago I was still a photographer and now
I'm influenza to be honest you do
n't have to be so interchangeable and
short-term but and I do
n't mean that negatively influenza that
always sounds so shitty and so negative in Germany
at its best if
what I do and create works, then
I influence a person out there
and whether it's a marathon, whether it's a
product, whether it's a pullover, whether the
water is always like that in things, but
someone writes to you with a large
account who  who is this guy man
you have a blue tick and then
exactly
a lot of people and then you
still have to write three four five times 20
times so they didn’t feel like
me at all what does the guy want
and so it was like that I  when i
met him because he said oh
actually this reality guy who
somehow and that is
or full i write him the
e-mail address that is not
that difficult to find out and so on
and
you absolutely spammed and especially me
I looked up on LinkedIn who
is German and works there I
wrote to all Germans who thought
they might have heard something from me did
n't help either and I
really hated for a year because
I'm three hard fans of this product
that has been my entire life
it's really the craziest product
I've ever had so it simply measures your
stress over the day and you I'm
a guy
who needs applause and this
product gives you applause every morning you
slept great when you can see you already know me  you
slept well there is great applause
you ran great or so that's
the whole time and why so sexy this
app is so cool because it's so
competitive and we have groups everywhere
with each other so I see what Joko
is doing tomorrow I see what so  so we we
competent so we all know
each other oh what to drink yesterday
and so on and that's exactly what I have to
say honestly so my
biggest problem was the alcohol
because I'm just too social drink too much
and then at some point we feel
sensum when the five of us  Drinking days at a time
and if it's only two beers
then you just sleep very, very
badly and then you are rewarded to
see that you leave that out and that
you also leave out meat and
that sometimes you are nothing in the evening
and that's why  has a much better
quality of sleep that's for me Bahn
with us is really one of the coolest
products so that's
why but the joint.com where I
have my link now here you can
possibly also
pay the numbers so that's
the money they have  but i have
a price so so i there is
just a price what a 12 month
partnership with me costs you
300 000 € now.  okay I take it
and um they changed it in part and
um put it in affiliate
links and so on and that's
why it's actually so that
I sometimes only get money out the back if I
give certain things via this link, so to speak,
I get money out the back and
that  has led to the fact that I meanwhile
and now everyone knows who I am
because I'm number 2 in the history of the
Philly now it's
okay again with Rogen is even bigger
but all the others and that's when we're talking
about patma homes by Michael Fels of
really relevant  Athletes, um, they ask
themselves who is going on in this crazy then number
two and what is going on there and
of course I'm a bit proud of it
but well I would
n't do that otherwise I think you lose
that what I've never done before like
that  and is also not a classic
affiliate that I somehow
get so and so much money per swipe or something like that
but that is something in between but
is what we uh yes that is
works
since I run and now mainly
run but also do other sports
we are in between and
I benefit from the fact that
a hub and Adidas are already close
to each other, so they actually
come from a classic hero
marketing situation, I would say, where
they are highly successful world champion
athletes but also IWC but also
Porsche  So it's actually always the
same that I'm the normal one,
Jever, so there's this term, I
always call me achieva, someone who
takes on something and then also
creates it and your change
or lose weight, so you know,
35 now 35
kg133
to do it and then you said I
'll do my thing how many months
before the start 6 months and then you
prepared yourself, really professional
triathlon trainer Philipp, who
comes from Heidelberg,
so the whole thing has to be run, you can really
say, but no plum, um
the topic of
running time and so on a
few years ago it was always cycling,
I still do a
lot, so I'm also on the last
partner you can say is
Schwalbe and with whom I ride bikes and
and also a bike tire  and make
products and so on and various things
and have my fifth one, so to speak, that's
pretty impressive here
now, guy now with IBC with Porsche
with Adidas, they're
really big global brands that they say,
okay, somehow we think they're cool and
this pusher mentality
trained that's all of course
documented the videos they make and that
there were videos made about it and so and in the
end what time did you walk
when you put a knife in me
what I had planned and
really opened my mouth very wide
I was under 4 hours and
no, I didn't manage that, yes, the
crucial point now, look
critically anyway because you think I'm
assuming the strawber result there is a
difference between the clock because I
mistakenly made a huge mistake
I'm with our
strange manufacturer  who makes running watches like this
SmartWatch and there was a
setting wrong which in turn only
tracked movements who had no
connection at the beginning that’s why the clock started 40
seconds no 48 seconds later
and these 48
seconds are pretty crucial because
the official time is 4 hours  0
minutes and 41 seconds the time on
my wrist was three hours 59 38
or something like that. I had a difference between
and that's why I only think IWC from
now on um never again with any such
smart [ __ ] because it
's actually partly unreliable what's
happening there  it's
for someone so it's all right yes
it's a world record at 2 hours is
about faster yes but well that
's what we're talking about people who
were born for it so to speak and I
think in the running area four hours is
n't really to be taken very seriously
I think if you run 53 330
or less than three hours you have
to take it a bit seriously because you are a runner like that but but
still yes I am totally
satisfied I am that was
awesome too so I feel like I
have no idea I have never been like this  as fit as I
am right now, you know, this
morning I ran for three quarters of an hour to
spielhafen from our friend Olaf and
so on and so naturally
it was a blatant life-changing
moment and above all and that was
actually the hottest thing about all
this time horizon  of six months
he has been living like this for
20 [ __ ] years, so I've been
thinking about what I'll be doing in the next
six months and that's really what
I'm actually talking about, I always talk about a
year so I know roughly when
the year is up to me  actually
it's half a year away and I found that
the coolest thing about the thing that you
just take something up front that you
can do in half a year and
half a year is really not that long
and almost everyone can do it
everyone can have it for the half marathon within
half a year, I
mean you
dyed your hair somehow then you could see and so
I would say but everything possible
afterwards then shaved off your hair so it
’s like that you’re staging it now
and  celebrist yes
you can only do that now yes I thought it was
really good but I have to
say that the trainer comes from the
triathlon and recognized relatively quickly
that his wife is
Germany's best triathlete Laura
Philipp's name is und  she's going to
set a world record now too, let me say in
red, and she's going to win the Ironman this
year because it's just
organized by people like that, no plum said I
know someone and he talked me into it
if he wanted to
put it negatively, but from a second  1
I found him really cool because people surround you
so you have to do these things then there
are automatically people around you too
but how many people are currently
working for me
that means then the videografter
exactly one video type one PI and
two  operations people for the
brand for couples exactly and they also
on all other projects but then
you still have one of those
people who live with you for a while sometimes
support people visiting so
that’s it, well, well, we  have a good
guest room
that's also on tripki we'll get
to that in a moment and thought to myself okay
what the [ __ ] is going on when no
plum visited you and uhm
honorary plum format where he generally accompanies people
from the social media
universe for a day and stuff  there was
a bit there with you in Newport there was a
scene for me that was
really actually I
said what what are they doing there I
think I think it's kind of let down in the context
you
're both naked in one I'm sleeping
exactly
and then at some point it came,
I think that's clear to everyone, that
's not quite tight and
accordingly it was all already, everything
fell asleep immediately, that's
one of the fascinating things about
no flame that just falls asleep within
44 seconds, it doesn't matter
600,000 sweet that's real traffic  but it
's unbelievable I never expected that
so if there's a blueprint
lifehack OMR for the report whatever
personal branding whatever um
then it's if Kai Pflaume
can come visit you then do everything
for it so it wasn't clear to me before
me  I don't like it very much and find it very
cool what he does and
goes through life like this and above all he is a
loyal friend
yes I know I would never put myself on the same
level as him
and but that's probably why he's a professional youth
and I
think  that may be
de facto I didn't do it out of tactics, he
asked me and
I said yes, I pressed it so briefly
because it's private too and
then I realized, oh actually
I'd like it to be just for
me internally  that's what I mean, I used to
make a lot of live DVDs for concerts of material from Toten Hosen of whatever and that was always
the main reason you want to
hold something and moment what you
can then put on the shelf at some point
man and that  I really miss that
I don't uh, that's how my life in
Newport Beach was, I notice that now when
I keep telling you how I
lived here on the houseboat or how
my life in Hamburg or wherever
I don't have a clean one  Medium
where I can say look, that's how it was
now and that's why I finally said
okay we'll do it now and at the
time
a bit more privately so you know,
besides the marriage bed, we're
already at school from my kids what that  The
main reason is why we live there,
it was a private decision
to go to America and not a
professional one, we wanted to
do it for our children and also
show it there, which I never do,
so women and children are completely taboo on
Instagram  they exist in the podcast, so
I talk about the fact that they exist, but I
keep them out as much as possible,
um, and I have that,
they are not visible in the video,
but theresa, for example, is
up and and says  something from
behind my wife and erm that was
out of the convert for me so and
so a bit anyway I found the
video good afterwards I also tried
not to kill a plum I have to
admit so I put so much sport into it
the worst kind of sport
cycling at the end where he's never sat
on his racing bike until then and then
I thought I'll break it
there's the end of Kai plumes fitness
isn't that's the end of mine
so he finished me and
no chance to work there somehow
also lives like a professional sport from time to time
is also with us now he moderates
one day and therefore also regular
contact then he calls me from the car
where are you from yes I was just doing
performance diagnostics and that  and
then I think I also have devices at home
where you
can expand your lung volume, all
sorts of things, well, that's
well beyond what is
normal, yes, but
definitely everything I do here and
we'll get to that now  the other
columns maybe briefly in my life
and what is there so that the community
is important to me, so that human
encounters are also important and that I'd
rather do something for 1000 people than for
a million because I've already
learned that I just don't  works
so a million people don't listen to me
point and accordingly I think there
was nothing better every single one
quotes this video because every single one
totally so it was for my brand
building I think the best thing
that could have happened in the last five years
was this video with  Kai Pflaume because it's
just sensational with a moderator in a storytelling
because it's explainable you sit down
you press play and after 47
minutes you know I don't know how
long the video is going to be you know what I'm
doing and that doesn't exist otherwise  That's
never happened before, so you know you
have to have someone explain what I'm
doing and what else happens and
he did it and
I totally underestimated how important it
is and I've been benefiting
incredibly since 5  months of because every
single one who comes to a community
event somewhere quotes this video and
always says that I thought it was cool
then I saw that ah and there and whatever
it was really straight and by
the way no plum cube immediately at
6asche by the way  Shopping he is
also a real lucky band
he is also in such a lucky pot
as I like shortly after the birth
because he really without gambling
immediately sex a couple so I was
I had prepared such an increase in
funny other games
because  I sometimes
help a little bit until we have high percentages
I didn't need to stole everything from him
immediately Pointe here I
just roll a 66
partnerships about your support so
where you know something to give, so to
speak, and now you
said community but community  is also for me
I understand now somehow connected
with things that you enjoy 9 goals
so that was the marathon goal has it been
reached is there the next measles
or do you already have the next
thing you would like to do or where do
you say that  is my next storyline,
which I now follow for six months or
so, running together with Adidas now
under four hours, hopefully at
some point in Berlin, so they will run
again in Berlin in September, that's
one of the chorus of things I want to do
there too  a bit of a community
with 50 to 100 people
running a home marathon somewhere before that and
because the limit to the marathon is a bit too
big, I think and I only do that
with three people, so we'll soon be looking for
people who might then train with me
there
even be invited to America and
that's something like that for me the blueprint
of what I want to do the adidas
quasi enabler will be a
hopefully experience of three other
people together with me that the
four of us will then create something and
even the brand values  are transported
by Adidas namely that they
are also enablers to get going movements
and and maybe to
live a healthier lifestyle and erm
they
let me tell the story because that's the one
that's already on what I always do
n't understand and  Of course, to this day it's
also sometimes the case that people
contact brands with people with reach
and then they want them to talk in their
community or audience or
whatever, which is total nonsense because
the only chance you have is that
the person in their way like you  always whatever
does but videos photos
podcast was always like that he has an
audience and or at best even
a community and then he should
do something where he believes or she of course
what works with your brand and
you shouldn't talk into it anymore
by the way, so everything that is said
is from brandseite it's important
that the product because I know the other one
you find better no just let him
do it then it will be an authentic
product everything else is no longer
authentic because there's no
other out there that's easy  also no
controller so there is only one from
promised just so authentic is
only real or not real and um if you
talk purely as a brand as a
client and even worse and that
's my spearhead I
really wouldn't be a fan of
advertising agencies anymore because they do that  well, one
thing advertising agencies do 100% they
make products less authentic because
they have a say it is absolutely as soon as you
involve an advertising agency it is
automatically by definition no longer
genuine because someone else is still having a say
that's just the way it is either it's
from customers or from  the brand or
something is real or it is from the
influencer content creator, whatever is
real, but if a
third party has a say then it finally becomes
gray and somehow that’s why I ca
n’t work with advertising agencies, so I
only work with customers directly  I ca
n't do that for me, also because
the output is really, really
bad of me because I don't
understand it, I have to understand what he wants
and, above all, he has to understand what I'm
actually doing and that's what you do
a lot with the partners now  very direct
and really cool and one but they
all have one thing in common that agency can be
interposed because I can't
manage it anymore because the product
was really always bad when he
was interposed by an agency and that's
why I don't really think it's anymore like
me  I wouldn't found an
advertising agency now if I if I'm
suitable for that
yes now cars and watches and and and and
sports clothes that of course also very
very perfect for your stuff if you
think about it now how do I
advertise for I don't know um yeah but
underestimate it  or something like that it's gotten
a bit more difficult again
the five people all have
advertising agencies that do their consumer that they do
everything well but
they don't do me because that does
n't work so I'm just talking about
myself who aren't talking against but they
have  Right, you now, so to speak,
my own things, of course, so to
speak,
the marathon in Berlin,
so sporty, I've already said two or three
things, red, I'll ride the
bike course, the Ironman, in red,
there's a swimmer in the relay, then
I'll take over and ride my bike and
Eugen  the guy from krafttrainers what the
hottest run community in the world is
full of awesome typically not met anyone like that for a long time
coincidence i took
a picture of his girlfriend before trust between
five years ago or something and
just got along well with them and got along well with her
well with him  understood and
they were visiting me now and they
were just he's just there trying
hard he works a word that
I recorded in the Matze hillscher podcast with
Jeremy fragrance and since then I've been
thinking a lot about it he works
courageously and in the end it's just the word
Courage is what I a ask of my
employees and B I'm
probably already quite good because
I try with a lot of effort to
do whatever I do,
so I try I don't do anything
half-heartedly I actually
always try  approaching it as courageously as possible
and I don't think I'm
that bad so the triathlon
Paul says it's a bit one of
the solo
yes I do sometimes that's
why Philipp is the triathlon
trainer who in turn guides me to
the marathon  Preparation for la was
all about three things so I was
excited to run and ride my bike and
not just run for la so now
I already have that like a runner no so for
la I had no then so
for the marathon I wanted to run
I have  trained in three sports
because they're similar things and that
was what made me so cool because I
kind of take turns it wasn't
boring so I didn't
run all the time and just always ran and
I didn't do a single long run
on Sundays which is yes  everyone else in
the prep is doing sports
suggests triathlon
could be a topic for you yes and then
you are also somehow active in the culinary arts
with the scales I mean I have five
partners that you
named them first because you yes  a
commercial imperialist are the money
the picture money was i would actually
write my own stuff in the first row but now we have already
started so
come on then i have to i was in
a russian band of my brother
and he now has a welcome
said you imperialist how are things going with
the imperialists that's why I got the
word but
money and numbers are important
maybe I'm doing a business podcast
yes and I always don't understand it when
you then where else do you talk about
what moves the world insofar as I
have there  uh professionally
so Paris is the own products
clothes that is an affine first the
podcast I heard it was
made seven strokes
next we have in our own
production that is the cooking room what you
said is also our own cooking
booklet that I and my wife
conceive now a
new issue is coming out and about four a year
who want to bring it out again are
photographed on the iPhone are simply collections of
recipes different topics
now prepes comes first about clean
so a bit of Californian
clean healthier cuisine and
of course lives off it when I can cook
than not cooking as Bernd whoever
then everyone can cook it out there and
I take photos with the iPhone
on top and do it the
three of us do it that's my assistant I have
someone else who comes in on Tuesdays and
Fridays in Newport Beach and
he comes  then over there and writes
the recipes to my wife and I
cooking but there is a logic
behind it or
may print 15,000 half is not such a
small edition that all sells
correctly via the online shop and what costs 15 €
sells
quite quite 15,000
so  Youtube so yes of course
all of them are a
business so that's why it's
not quite so that's why it's
actually one
now fits from Paul that my
newsletter which is recorded every Friday evening in
Newport Beach and then
Saturday morning plays with the
time difference  and it
's also marketed by the way, so it's
also gifts, it's also at the start and
it's unfortunately fully booked for
this year, but I think the price is far too
low for that
[laughter]
that's
no, that's not true, that was of course
now just a silly joke on whatever
i also have a lot of costs
and they but no so financially
everything is fine right now and i have i still
spend the money i
earned last year so
i still have zero  really financial
values ​​so I don't have an apartment
I don't have a house I live for rent I
uh shoot out everything that happens I
've bought a lot of things
lately for example a
consumer Porsche
[Laughter] I do
n't think you have to keep it there  unfortunately to
admit honestly and I have so
I have an 81 and an 87 in
America awesome that's
what people are interested in and
then I have tripki or tripy you
probably don't really know
and don't know exactly very well and has
something to do with three too  because and and
stumbling over recommendations is an app
that was released three months ago
and hasn't been that
unsuccessful since then,
but not that much talk about you yet because I
sometimes test projects first to see
how they feel and how it
is there and  even then at some point, for
example NFP is last year I
already released nfc's and at some point
it didn't feel right anymore
and then I stop again, so
I owe it to myself that I
try it and don't say from the start
I don't want to do it  and
chipki is something like that it's a travel app
and these are recommendations from me
personalized travel recommendations because,
as I said, I've traveled a bit,
I pick out cities and
write them down in six categories
hotel food
exercise a run uh something drink a
bar or a  Coffee and then said what
to shop and what's the sixth thing
I like has running route no that was
movement so she sees restaurant
I forgot no but she sees move
stay and
there are six categories and
three recommendations each for cities there are
already 14 hours  if you
want that, you have to get the tripkey app, it's
available on iOS and Android
everywhere,
that means it's not a business, but
of course it could be that you'll be another
partner at some point,
so I don't want to market it at the moment,
it's just really something  What was
kind of close to my heart somehow to
write down the times are
really my own recommendations,
always
I think Fynn Kliemann said it at the time,
I asked him what should I
do and in such decisions he is
always very, very good and I
trusted him  that a website for me in
2008 was kind of a block and
then an app is still
closed and it also looks much, much better,
so the app is really slick and
clean and there is just a city and
then there are three things  You know that
up and down and then on the right and left
you write back to the city and then
you can save with that there are now
14. There is a new city every Friday
so it is also a lot of work
because each time they are actually 18 block entries
I have to  always
looking for something I have to
write something down you have to write a little text
everything is also in
English that was also important to me not just to
be German all the time it's much
much more international he you can
already tell that's just
San Francisco and  uhm Japan Beach is
of course in there but also Heidelberg and so
always and yes but in the end to
complete the five own
projects
and that’s how I really tick with that
I earn five external partners and that’s
what I learned
for my own came balance
and because I say five things
when I enter into five external
cooperations with advertising partnerships,
I also have to
do five things of my own that really only me and
no one participates in, so no no no
none of this organization has
any involvement or any kind of
or whatever  otherwise it's
just me and only dependent on me
and um that's what I learned
from the imbalance from last
year I have even cooler apps so
just products that's Paris long
with 30 kg a wine that's still available
then there's a pair with
kraftlink they're some startup guys from
cologne and I make a bar with them
because I find the word funny
and then we have that's on
the refrigerated shelf it's also a bit of an
innovation very common in America that the
rule  are not dry but are
therefore more violent and it is also
high pro TV
next to the partnerships next to lonely
now over the coal kolabos exactly
bags okay
bike with Focus I did everything then there then
I do uh par Drink
Club uh Negroni with Siegfried uh exactly
really a lot at work
yeah no honestly not I mean
I live in America and I'm
actually always free from 1 p.m. because all
these topics take place in Germany
and I just make too many
messages for tomorrow at 6 a.m. and then
I have to send one
Take a deep breath for an hour and work through it and so on,
but in the end A
I have someone by my side
who structures it very well and B
it's like a project list, so I
have exactly that on my wall, so
I have to do the bike now
So Paul is just writing things down here,
you can see that such
an overview is then a support
step and then there are two or three
mentor things that I do, so there's
just the support line,
we'll shorten it, I'm not that much
talk about it but then it's
really balanced when you five
collaboration so real
advertising partnership but man we
're here now let's say um what kind of category is there
for me
insurance insurance and and we
are Allianz was or or or we
are them  Techniker
Krankenkasse or someone and that will be a
good fit and then you would
say no, I don’t know I do
n’t know right now, always listen to everything and
look, so if in
doubt I might have to do a
sixth project of my own and a
sixth project  start so that I
can earn it yes but at the
moment it's not like I'm 20
on I have three open pitches
where I always and that's you
asked again yourself and want to
do something well then sometimes there are
people  they say we don't even want
to do anything but what always happens then and by the way they
all have that in common there
is always a conclusion so uh all
things are never requested as they
happen then but the questions hey do
n't we want to do something and then
I go in  a creation and I'm
thinking with David Selection that's
actually an advertiser who when Apple
was an agency and one of my closest
friends in America and then I
really sit there and then
we conceive what could you make of my
world what a good and  so on and
at the end a PDF is created which
I can show you, even
Paul Taschen has a PDF because the
assessability of the whole thing is an extra
mile that you have to walk, it
's also really time-consuming, so I have no idea
I can do that for you  my phone is over there
but can now show adidas PDF, for example, so
that's it, we're going out for the
designs, I even take photos
for it so that you can understand, there's
a photo of me in the leather jacket
with a phone in my hand because I'm
holding  I'm not a runner but I
just do insta stories while running and
so on I can tell the story from
the perspective of the runner I
have to but visually I want to do it
because everyone really explains they
are self-explanatory so that
's one thing  yes that someone says let's
do something that
happened that's how it
happened to me at least so you only get a job
if he
can then pass it on to five people and the
five people are also convinced and that
means there is always  an introduction
who is Paul Rip and what does he
actually do for the brand not
cheap with you said yes costs
so you have to think about whether you
want to make the investment
another question because a lot of
course now depends on you as a person  as a
brand, obviously
in doubt about your health, but it feels to
me that it also depends a
lot on the reach, and that
is above all now with
Instagram Podcast you also have it, but
instagram is already the dominant
medium for you  and now
you can already follow
something is always changing and tiktok is coming and the
question is uh, are you worried about
Instagram it's been two or three
years now and the
reach is a bit as worthless
as it is nowadays  Facebook reach
I'm not worried about any of that I do
n't care at all so we can
throw it away and get rid of it I can
open an ice cream parlor tomorrow in Heidelberg I really don't give a damn
so I love doing it
and I think it's really cool right now and
I'm very proud of it  that's why
I'm telling you here now, even if it
's over tomorrow, it doesn't give a [ __ ], really, really,
I don't give a damn
they're
all healthy that's all cool so I'm
dead my career that doesn't matter at all
so as long as they have the motto in what for
5 years in this case
really totally that's also what
I learned at the beginning of the conversation
of course I had there  I'm scared
all the time and that's where I
learned it's actually cool, so
maybe I can't
afford to do it the way it is,
but the way it is now, it's all
cool and I have very
good friends like that  So it's absolutely
crazy how many people
have actively reported and
yes, and those who
have really reported as people as friends and
I appreciate that very much and I've
already learned that it's much
more than the nonsense we do  have now
discussed here for two hours and
that I actually
have a lot of fun doing it right now and
I think it's really cool so I'm
still full of energy so I think
at least I'll go and because tik tok
to do
zero because it doesn't me
So not interested I don't have yet I have
a tiktok account I think but I do
n't know the login data for it or
look at other apps according to the motto
what's new is no idea I
thought the claphouse was really cool well what
talk like a waterfall like  you
may have already done
that's great but then it was gone again
sorry so don't give a damn so I have no
idea what happens next so I do
n't know at all and I
so then it's just Instagram but
Instagram it won't go away and
so I'm there  I would rather quote the theory of
1000 fans and I
think I have people that you out of
1000 people who have been with you for the last ten
years so a longer paper is also
a bit older but it's sort of
like building a community that you from
who will get so much back because
you may have given them so much
in their lives so you hear
inspired decisions to make differently
you also have your way of life has
become a bit different that in case of doubt they will
still consume your product for a relatively long time
when you go to  For example,
bringing out half of the cooker yourself or
doing an ice cream shop or because then in the end
I really have to say
that and that’s what drives me the whole time,
how much, you know,
sometimes I think I got you in the last episode
then I always
talked about investing, that I often
took photos for free, whatever, and
then I
thought about it afterwards, that's actually
not at all, that was never an investment, I
actually just did it to a lot of
people because I really
enjoyed it  Makes people happy and
they all came back
tenfold at some point, but not because it
was an investment for something in return,
but because it was a real hearty thing
because people
feel it and so on and that was also
something where we used to be
you and I hooked up a bit because you
said no wonder you have such a
network how hospitable you
are as Theresa and Paul and so on
that made me really angry at
the back because I'm not
hospitable because I have a good
network
I know  but still i wasn't
mad at you but that that
's what i really care about
hundreds of people who like to
be your guest because they
kind of know you from afar and
think like everyone okay in l.a what does
he do  I would like to be able to look with the scenes
and it
struck me that people, yes, you know,
we are in similar
bubbles, are curious about your
life and also find it inspiring
if, when in doubt, they
have a more normal life in Germany than  Doctor or
lawyer or
whatever you do
and then you think to yourself, okay,
that wig is awesome, hey, I would like to
take a look at that and then you get a
few insights and then you thought, well,
that has always had its conscience, shame,
that has to be said
I think everyone who has
been there is very impressive
because you have the greeneck
grill there and then you have a full
drawer and of course you can
cook perfectly and it's just very generous
then there and you  has the feeling okay um
that's already a nice day
but well that's also well yes I'm
glad that you had a nice day
and that's also but that's
my goal that I can bring people with us
we're coming somehow
I don't know with Lukas  and Tobias and
Weiber of course still in exchange to this day
am one of the ones I met there for the first time
Tobi bauka
ultra cool and
accordingly so it is of course the greatest
quality you can have that
actually inspiring people
somehow you even work like that in their lives
can that they remember
that I think that's a really, really big gift
and I'll
always be grateful for that anyway, um, that
's what
really bothers me a lot and what I also see as
I often see is that the diverse
whether they are startups or whether it is burning
they are so egocentric and
think so often about what do we get out
of it what is it for me that they
really don’t need to be surprised that
somehow works very
quickly of course correcting that because I’m
trying to do that too  not to do it that way for me,
so I don't really
mean finances and there's no question at all, and
I always think money explains the
world very well, so I'm
really curious about it and I want to
make the podcast better with it, but I
wouldn't like to be like that myself now that
I think what's my advantage now,
so I don't think you do an
event like we do in
some cases now, when you
try to try everything out, you may also have to be
purely rational, there
's this old all the way to the quote
you  have to throw the money out of the window at the top
so that you can put it back in at the bottom,
I always
remembered that very well earlier at 100 and
then it’s rational again, but
I think some people just like to
throw it out, so you write and lo and behold in
your case it’s all there  uhm and so
I really treat everyone and I do
n't think I would accuse you of saying that it
somehow
works that way somehow media
attention is there is no cool
you were also thinking about
coming to the podcast
nope I don't feel like it but it'll
get you  probably something too and
I know that, but
you have to be able to manage it,
but I think there has to be
this level on the other side
that you have simply been great
because of your case and also as a
brand and also as a customer and  that's something
um then it'll be very easy to get out
so
I'm already asking myself what can
that be new in a year so now
we want that yes I hope that you
're up for it again
but now it really went very very
structured so that that  and
thrown away in the end yes,
I'm old, what can you say,
congratulations
on the life situation and also on
the happiness that you radiate,
yes, I'm happy for you and I hope
it's back here, okay, um,
I'll get closer and dress a
little too  Inspiration from hey you so
now the last time we
went out here I don't know if
you still remember that and I have a little
oh I'll find out now what I
'm worth myself without Joko without
national team without matter without
Toten Hosen without formula  1 without you are
Hamilton without whatever because up until then
I always
hid behind I was always plus one like that
and I know it also helped very strategically so
what's the point you said yourself,
um,
that was it  clever of you
that you sometimes have the chance
yes I want yes yes can be because
they are not but still gone and have what
is now without exactly and I'm waiting
afraid well I've never been as
afraid as I was a year and a half ago
never psychologically
as
shaky as I was a year and a half ago and
interestingly enough I've never
been as firm as I am now and so happy
and so clear and that's nice
because of that so
congratulations on that I thank you
for coming in I'm always happy
when you're here in  Hamburg is part of my life
and then of course
you want to miss a festival you have to say that
was really saying that's um, especially
since that would have given a lot of
points people I would have
liked to introduce to you and
have their own stage like that I'll get them
next year  can find a little
[music]
solution maybe listeners in
good names for the stage
alright thanks for coming around
thanks for the invite